today I'm going to be ranking reddit's
top skincare tips I'm going to be
talking about the science behind them if
there's any and then ranking them on
this scale I know it's a bit of a cliche
that news sites still content ideas from
Reddit but since I donated thousands of
hours to modding it in the past it's not
as bad if I do it I think hi I'm
Michelle of loudmouth and Beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and big
fan of cheap skincare tips like I said I
was a moderator on Reddit skincare
addiction forum for about four years so
I've seen a lot of these tips before and
now I'm seeing a lot of them again being
recycled on places like tiktok how I got
this list it's not the most robust
methodology I searched Reddit using
Google because that is what you do I
looked up skincare tips and skincare
hacks and then I went through the top 50
search results for each of those and I
looked for posts that had over a hundred
upvotes then I took the top 10 comments
of those tallied the math and then got
the top 10 and here they are in reverse
order this time with my ranking I'm
gonna make it clear this is how how much
of a difference I think they'll make for
people in general so if one of these
tips will work really well for a tiny
group of people I will talk about that
but it's probably not going to score
that well on this rubric so keep that in
mind number 10 is slugging this actually
showed up a lot less than I expected
slugging is when you put on a really
thin layer of Vaseline or petroleum
jelly as your final step at night you
put it on over the rest of your skincare
and then you go to sleep and you end up
shining a bit like a slug which is where
that name came from back when the name
slugging was invented this was when
snail was also really popular in Reddit
probably around
2014-ish so it seemed to make sense that
this would also be like I don't know
another mollusk related name your skin
is more permeable at night there is
higher trans epidermal water loss and
what that means is you have lots of
water evaporating that means your skin
can dry out more easily and so you end
up wanting to trap in water more which
this works really well for because
petrolatum is the gold standard
occlusive it's really good at Sealing
water the other thing that happens is
your skin can get dried out and itchy
and tight and again this helps prevent
that on top of that more hydrated skin
can also let in some skincare
ingredients a bit more easily into the
Skin So this can also have an effect of
helping your skincare ingredients
penetrate a bit more deeply slacking
went viral again on tick tock not that
long ago it's very weird being a bit of
a dinosaur in Internet years because
this seems like such an ancient Trend to
me and of course even before Reddit
people's grandmas were doing this so
yeah not a new hack I do like this
because it is a very cheap hack and a
lot of people do have a jar of Vaseline
lying around that they will never get to
the bottom of so it is something that I
think most people can try without too
much risk some people have asked me
about the environmental impact and it
should be pretty low because petroleum
jelly is a byproduct of oil as long as
we are digging our petroleum to burn in
cars then patrolling jelly is going to
be quite cheap because it doesn't
require a lot of extra resources to make
I've talked about this before in my
video on environmental claims so check
that out if you're interested the
downsides of this is first off your skin
gets really sticky and your hair and cat
fur and dust just gets stuck to your
face it's pretty annoying a bit
off-putting it can also potentially push
irritants deeper into your skin again if
it's pushing active ingredients it is
also pushing other things as well so
that can potentially make your skin care
a bit too much for you but otherwise I
think it is definitely worth a try for
most people so I'm going to put that up
here in yes less is more or you don't
need 10 steps I think this is a very
good tip there are a lot of products out
there that don't really have proven
benefits and a lot of skincare products
overlap in what they do so if you're
using a whole bunch of things there's
probably something not really necessary
in there that you can cut out and you
can save time and money and probably
also prevent freaking out your skin too
much if you have sensitive skin then the
more stuff you use the higher the risk
of using something that might interact
with your skin in a bad way and by bad
way I don't really mean like permanent
damage it's probably more just like
irritation there are also a lot more
multifunctional products out there these
days so you can probably cut down on the
number of products you're using and I
think there is a lot of mindless
consumerism going on people get excited
over products that they see on social
media they start buying it before
thinking about whether it actually fits
into their skincare routine in a way
that makes sense also when people do
this they tend to introduce way too many
products to their skin at the same time
like you get the parcel you open it and
then you just slap everything on your
skin as well as freaking out your skin
that also means that you can't really
tell what is actually working this is
something that we use a lot in
experimental design and science we
control the variables that means we keep
everything constant except for one thing
which we change and that means if we
only change one thing then if we have
something changing in our skin we have
an outcome changing there is a higher
chance of that thing that we changed
having caused that outcome so I don't
think explain that very well but
basically if you change one thing and
one thing changes then the link between
those is going to be a lot stronger you
can make a much stronger conclusion
about it anyway at the same time I don't
entirely subscribe to the whole
everything other than three products is
a waste of time and money some people's
skin can benefit from extra steps and
having extra bits in their routine some
people do also just have fussier skin
and there aren't too perfectly
formulated products on the market that
address all their needs they have to
kind of fudge it a bit more with more
different products so essentially
everyone's skin is different I highly
recommend working out your own skin
needs and concerns and then narrowing it
down that way and not getting swept up
in hype about products if you want a
guide to working out your skid needs and
concerns and figuring out a basic
routine that works for your skin you can
check out my ebook so I'm going to put
that in solid I think if it says
sometimes less is more then I would
agree with that a bit more but yeah it's
not something that works for everyone on
to number eight which is sleep on your
back so there are two main reasons that
people recommend this number one is
something called Sleep lines sleep lines
are a special type of wrinkle that are
vertical the reason we get wrinkles is
it's a combination of skin quality and
repeater creasing with skin quality it's
stuff like how much collagen you have
how thick your skin is the thinner and
more uneven it is the more likely it is
to form a wrinkle with the same sorts of
faucets the other part of wrinkles is
repeater creasing so things like crow's
feet expression lines on like your
forehead and between your brows that's
why getting Botox injections can help
with wrinkles because it stops your
muscles from repeatedly creasing those
things and kind of etching that
temporary wrinkle that you get in motion
into a permanent crease so as well as
expression lines we also sleep for about
eight hours a day and our heads are
heavy so if you're kind of smushing your
face and sideways or like frontwards
into your pillow every day with the
whole weight of your head then you can
can get these creases on your face these
creases tend to go up and down on your
face and they don't line up with any
other sort of expression so it has to
pretty much come from sleeping in
particular positions so sleeping on your
back is a way of avoiding this and there
are products like pillows that purposely
try to make you sleep on your back
there's also a sort of practical aspect
which is just not getting all your stuff
on your face onto your pillow and vice
versa so you're keeping your skincare
working on your skin and not working on
your pillow your pillow also stays
cleaner for longer and you don't have
extra dirt and I don't know hair oil and
sweat from four days ago going back onto
your face so this can make a big
difference for some people who have acne
for example the problem with this tip
though is you also don't want to
sacrifice your quality of sleep some
people can get used to a new sleep
position pretty easily some people
cannot for example if you have sleep
apnea issues then you might not be able
to sleep on your back without having a
really Disturbed sleep so this is a bit
of a your mileage will vary kind of tip
I wouldn't recommend this to absolutely
everyone but if you are worried about
sleep lines or if you are finding that
your skin is getting aggravated by
getting Gunk from your pillow onto it
then this is probably worth a try this
will go somewhere between mer and solid
I think I'm going to put it in solid and
I might reconsider it number seven is
oily and acne Pro skin can need
moisturizer this one I really like
because it applies to me this was
actually one of the things that got me
into skincare in the first place I had
oily and acne Pro skin I went for years
trying to find good Solutions a lot of
that involved putting alcohol on my skin
and just drying out my skin a lot then
at some point I started putting on
glycerin-based moisturizer on my skin
and rosehip oil and that made a huge
difference my skin actually improved a
whole bunch and it seemed really
counter-intuitive at the time but now it
makes perfect sense because oil and
water are not the same thing if your
skin produces enough of its own oil that
oil is actually first off not very good
at sealing and water and secondly the
oil from your skin is not exactly the
same as the oil that you're putting on
in skincare products your skin oil
oxidizes easily and when it oxidizes it
can Harden and then start clogging up
your pores it can also irritate your
skin so if you're putting on other oils
onto your skin it can change the
composition of oils on your skin overall
one of the reasons this makes such a big
difference is that water is really
important for your skin it signals to
your skin to do certain things for
example if your skin is more hydrated
then it actually exfoliates itself a bit
more easily so a lot of people who have
oily acne prone skin they might try to
dehydrate their skin because they think
that their skin is oily it needs less
oil and then what happens is your skin
doesn't exfoliate itself properly it
doesn't desperate properly is the
technical term instead it starts coming
off in big chunky flakes this tip won't
work for everyone obviously it is only
really for people who have oily skin who
were drying out their skin in the first
place and some moisturizers can possibly
make things worse as well so this is a
bit of a niche tip again but I think it
is useful I'm going to put it in
probably oh I'm gonna have to put it in
may even though I like this tip a lot
just because it doesn't really apply to
everyone but it does apply to a lot of
people who tend to be on skincare
addiction because that subreddit is
mostly for younger people who tend to
have more acne problems number six is
use hyaluronic acid or moisturizer on
damp skin this one is a bit complex
where this comes from is humectants
humectants are one of the three main
types of moisturizers they're the ones
that work by holding onto water so they
latch onto water and that slows it from
evaporating now there is all this stuff
from the internet where it says if you
have more humid weather then it's going
to grab water from the atmosphere and I
don't know drag it down to your skin but
if you have a dry climate then it is
going to pull water out of your skin and
dry it out none of this is really
supported by the evidence everyone has
trans epidermal water loss which is
water evaporating through the top layers
of the skin from the epidermis so
basically your insides are like 70 water
and then it lowers as it gets off so
yeah water is constantly evaporating off
your skin that's probably the main
source of where the humectants get their
water they just grab onto this water as
it goes past now in a hyaluronic acid
product or moisturizer you're going to
have a lot of water generally it is
going to be upwards of 60 water probably
closer to 80 most of the time this is
more than enough water to saturate all
the water binding spots on hyaluronic
acid or any other humectant in your
product so adding extra water is really
not necessary it's already holding on to
the maximum water if you add extra water
it's just going to be floating around
away from the humectant it's not going
to make a difference but it does feel
like it's making a difference and I
think one of the main reasons is that
your skin just has more water at the
start your skin is just wetter so it
feels immediately more hydrated rather
than having to wait for that trans
epidermal water loss to start getting
trapped by whatever occlusives for
example that you have in your
moisturizer and this extra water can
take a while to evaporate so yeah your
skin does feel a bit more hydrated at
the start but if you went off and tested
your skin maybe an hour or two hours
afterwards I don't think there would be
that much of a difference one situation
where I do think this can make a big
difference is if you are coming out of
the shower you've been in the shower
your skin has been soaking in water for
a fair bit if you put on moisturizer
immediately that can make a difference
compared to putting on moisture as I say
15 minutes afterwards and that's because
water does actually make skin more
permeable it's kind of ironic you're
adding more water and that water makes
your skin lose water more easily so if
you quickly slap on an occlusive when
your skin is still wet then that just
sort of slows down that evaporation that
boosted evaporation anyway long story
short if you like having extra water
then use it if you don't like using
extra water don't feel like you have to
because I don't know your moisturizers
are still in your water I'm gonna put
that one in
meh it's entirely a preference thing tip
number five use less actors or
exfoliants or rotate through them and
use more soothing and hydrating products
this is pretty similar to the less is
more tip I think people do tend to do a
bit too much to their skin especially
when they're starting out with skin care
when they're in that sort of excited
phase when they're just buying things
and slapping stuff onto their face and
trying to like throw everything up the
wall to see what sticks and I think this
tends to happen a lot especially with
people who are using harsher products to
try to attack their acne they're kind of
thinking if I attack my skin then I can
beat it into submission but the problem
with that is of course irritation and
inflammation can actually contribute to
acne a lot of people also overdo it with
exfoliants and that means you thin down
your Skin Barrier a bit too much those
dead layers of cells on the top of your
skin those are meant to protect the rest
of your skin the living layers from the
environment if you thinner too much then
your skin does really tend to suffer it
gets irritated more easily it gets
inflamed it gets itchy it's just not
really doing its job properly and it
takes a while to recover as well you
have to sort of just bench your skin for
two three weeks I have a video with my
friend Hannah on how how to recover
after doing this and again like I
mentioned before hydration can also help
with exfoliation you don't have to just
use harsh exfoliants so I'm probably
going to put this into solid I think it
is a tip that will work for most people
most people should probably try every
once in a while to just slow down on
their products and see if that actually
makes a difference to their skin because
if it does then you're going to save a
lot of time and money next tip is change
your pillowcases more I kind of talked
about this before in the sleeping on
your back part this is all about having
a dirty pillowcase and how that can
sometimes contribute to people's acne
again acne is probably the most common
skin problem on skin care addiction
there was even a product that was
dedicated to this idea it was like a
pillowcase and then on top there were
like layers of pillowcase materials so
you could use one each day and then like
peel off the top layer Chuck that in the
laundry have a fresh layer and then
after can't remember how many days you
would get to the bottom and then by then
your old Sheets Were coming back out of
the wash I've also seen people
recommending putting t-shirts onto your
pillow as like extra pillowcase covers I
think this tip can work really well for
some people but again it is a subset of
people a lot of acne does come from
factors other than just having dirty
stuff on your face so because it is such
a limited technique I'm probably going
to put it into I'm going to put it into
mare tip number three is
avoid saturated sugars and oils or cut
out dairy or heal your gut generally
diet and food advice I am really not a
fan of dietary advice on the internet
you can see that all of these are
actually pretty restrictive like
saturated sugars and oils are in a lot
of foods Dairy is often a lot of
people's diet and healing your gut is
just very general I think if you start
looking up healing your gut you end up
down some very weird rabbit holes so if
you suddenly start following these
really restrictive eating rules you can
end up with a really imbalanced diet and
it can even lead to eating disorders
I've even seen some dermatologists
mostly younger dermatologists giving the
sort of dietary advice on places like
Tick Tock from talking to a lot of
dermatologists if they're a bit more
older and experienced they tend to have
seen some of these issues in their
patients already so they are a lot more
cautious about giving this sort of
advice and some dermatologists have
themselves been affected by it and there
is some evidence that eating lower GI
foods can potentially help with acne and
cutting out certain types of Dairy but
it does need a lot of caveats because
the evidence for diet influencing your
skin is just so much less solid than for
things like products and particular
ingredients I talked about this in a
video collaboration I did with Dr
Angelie Marto and she's also written
some articles on it that you can check
out I think the way that the British
Association of dermatologists phrased
this advice is really quite good it's
possibly written by Anjali basically
what they say is if you've noticed that
a particular food might be causing
changes in your skin then try skipping
that particular food for a while and
observe what happens to your skin then
introduce it back into your diet and see
what happens so notice that this is
about a specific food and not like a
whole food group or a whole chunk of
your diet and also it's time limited so
it's like guiding you how to do this
experiment on yourself and not just
saying avoid all of this stuff which is
probably not that healthy so I'm gonna
put this in no because I think it does
probably introduce more problems than it
solves in general for people but if you
are going to try it make sure there is a
limit in terms of the foods involved
just try to minimize that as well as
minimizing the time period that you're
going to try it tip number two is use
tretinoin or use retinol pretty
straightforward advice I think this is
really good advice retinoids are just a
really good all-rounder class of
ingredients they tackle so many skin
concerns if you have gone towards skin
care for a reason then it is probably
going to tick off one of your reasons
they can increase collagen which reduces
wrinkles they can increase skin turnover
which reduces acne it also Smooths out
your skin and helps reduce pigment it
also normalizes pigment production it
also acts as an antioxidant so yeah they
also have the most evidence for them
helping with a whole bunch of things
some people's skin can't really tolerate
it very well but these days there are so
many products on the market there are
much more gentle ones there are ones
that are formulated specifically for
people who have issues with irritation
so I'm pretty sure there is a retinoid
out there for you I'm going to put this
up all the way at yes finally tip number
one I don't think this comes as a
surprise to anyone it's just wear
sunscreen again this is really good
advice it is something that can help
with pretty much all skin conditions UV
contributes to everything it contributes
to wrinkles it contributes to increased
pigment it also increases inflammation
which then indirectly leads to acne as
well as making a whole bunch of other
skin conditions worse like rosacea
chances are you are using skincare to
try to address one of these things that
uvian does so you are kind of wasting
your money on skin care if you're not
also protecting your skin from further
damage by UV I do find that Reddit
sometimes goes overboard with the sun
avoidance back when I was moderating I
would come across a lot of posts that
were like if you can see sunlight you
need to wear sunscreen people would ask
questions like do I need to wear
sunscreen to bed if I can see a little
bit of sunlight peeking out from around
my curtains I think that sort of hyper
Focus can be a bit unhealthy and this is
one of the reasons why I made this video
talking about how much sun you get
indoors I think in general people tend
to see things in black and white so Sun
versus no it's also a thing in clean
Beauty like does this have parabens yes
or no does this ingredient cause cancer
yes or no but when you start looking at
things like dose how much you're getting
how much UV how much parabens then you
can start to see what does and doesn't
make a difference and of course this
changes depending on your skin as well
and your susceptibility to some but
there are very very few people in the
world who are sun sensitive enough to
have to wear sunscreen to bed but yeah
wearing sunscreen definitely belongs on
the top tier so those were my rankings
of reddit's top skincare tips let me
know if you agree let me know if there's
an obvious tip that's missing from here
I've been really enjoying doing these
ranking videos because they're a bit
more chatty we can go into a bit more
deep discussion about things and not
just focus on technical stuff which is a
lot of my other videos so let me know if
you have any other ideas for ranking
videos If you enjoyed this video click
like And subscribe there are more
skincare videos popping up around me so
check those out as well